la esperanza de una tercera estrella
hizo explotar en Euforia a las calles de
Francia con una victoria de 2 a 0 contra
la sorpresa del torneo Marruecos
apuntan a lo que sería un hito
convertirse en la primera selección en
más de 60 años en levantar Dos copas del
mundo consecutivas
es enorme y dos veces seguidas eso no
pasa vivíe de champs se convertirá en
leyenda incluso más de la que ya es
sería algo muy loco muy loco
un partido cargado no solo por la
rivalidad sino también por el pasado
colonial las nuevas generaciones fruto
de la inmigración no se quedan ahora sin
motivos para seguir la fiesta todos
somos franceses después de todo
Marruecos jugó genial hicieron historia
para el fútbol africano en la Copa del
Mundo estamos felices a pesar de la
derrota y ahora continuaremos celebrando
porque tenemos ambas nacionalidades
Marruecos se convirtió en el primer
equipo árabe en llegar a cuartos de
final y el primer equipo africano en
disputar una semi de un mundial una
derrota agridulce pero que dejó al mundo
árabe con la frente en alto
los marroquíes jugaron un gran partido y
es suficiente que hayan estado entre los
cuatro mejores ningún país árabe o
africano había llegado antes a este
nivel no sé qué decir pero ellos son
héroes Argentina también dos veces
campeona del mundo sueña a la par de
Francia con una tercera estrella en la
camiseta y con llevar el título del
mundo a América del Sur será un duelo de
astros que el domingo se convertirá en
el centro del universo fútbol
[Música]